este video le enseñará Cómo usar sus
muletas sírvase ver todo el video antes
de usar sus
moletas las moletas le ayudarán a
moverse sin dejar caer el peso en el pie
o pierna lesionados si sufrió una lesión
o le operaron un pie o pierna quizá
necesite usar
muletas hablaremos sobre ciertas partes
de las muletas en este
video la parte superior de la muleta se
llama
almohadilla el mango que está en medio
se llama
agarradera la parte inferior de goma que
está en contacto con el piso se llama
punta de
muleta antes de usar muletas necesitará
estar seguro de que se ajustan
correctamente a su
cuerpo paso uno coloque una muleta
debajo de cada brazo a los lados del
cuerpo mientras está de pie paso dos
relaje los hombros y deje caer los
brazos sobre las muletas las almoadillas
de la muleta no deben tocar las
axilas paso tres verifique cuánto
espacio hay entre sus axilas y las
almohadillas deben haber 2 pulgadas o 5
cm de espacio entre
ambas es decir casi dos o tres dedos de
ancho este espacio evita que las
almohadillas de la muleta presionen los
nervios y los vasos sanguíneos de las
axilas
la presión en los nervios y venas puede
causar hormigueo y debilidad en el
brazo si las muletas no tienen la altura
correcta puede ajustarlas verifique las
instrucciones de uso de sus muletas o
Póngase en contacto con su proveedor de
cuidado de Salud si no está seguro de
cómo
hacerlo paso cuatro verifique la altura
de las agarraderas de las muletas sus
muñecas deben estar Al mismo nivel de
las agarraderas si las agarraderas no
tienen la altura correcta puede
ajustarlas verifique las instrucciones
de uso de sus muletas o Póngase en
contacto con su proveedor de cuidado de
Salud si no está seguro de cómo hacerlo
ahora usted aprenderá Cómo levantarse
con las
muletas paso uno estando de pie sobre su
pierna sana tome una agarradera con cada
mano paso dos apriete ambas almohadillas
a los lados de su pecho y parte alta de
los brazos no coloque sus axilas sobre
las almoadillas de las muletas para
sostener su
cuerpo usted sostendrá su peso con las
agarraderas paso tres separe las puntas
de las muletas y colóquelas suavemente
frente a usted en el
piso esto se conoce como un trípode o
base
triple ahora usted aprenderá Cómo
caminar con las
muletas asegúrese de estar viendo por
dónde camina no solo mire sus
pies También tenga cuidado al caminar
porque necesitará más espacio a ambos
lados del cuerpo para las
muletas paso uno mientras se mantiene de
pie con las muletas mueva las puntas un
paso hacia delante de usted paso dos
ahora recargue su peso sobre las
agarraderas de las muletas ahora
balancee la pierna lesionada hacia
delante paso tres de un paso con su
pierna
sana asegúrese de pisar bien el suelo o
dar el paso solo un poco delante de las
muletas paso cuatro mueva las puntas de
las muletas un poco hacia delante para
balancear su peso repita los pasos para
seguir
caminando en ocasiones su cirujano puede
permitirle poner peso a su pierna
operada cuando camine con
muletas se le puede pedir que solo toque
el dedo del pie en el piso para ibrar
pero sin ponerle
peso camine usando la mitad del peso que
normalmente usa para
hacerlo deje caer el peso que pueda
tolerar sobre su pierna
operada o no deje caer nada de peso en
su pierna cuando camine con las
muletas siga las instrucciones de su
cirujano sobre si debe poner peso y
cuánto en su pierna operada cuando
camine con las
muletas
ahora usted aprenderá a sentarse con las
muletas paso uno Póngase de pie al lado
de o frente a la
Silla paso dos mueva ambas muletas
debajo de sus brazos al lado
lesionado sosténgalo
paso tres agarre el apoyabrazos de la
Silla o siéntese con su otro
brazo paso cuatro extienda su pier
lesionada frente a usted y acérquese al
asiento y aquí está cómo levantarse con
las
muletas paso uno mientras está sentado
extienda su pierna lesionada frente a
usted paso dos mueva ambas muletas a su
lado lesionado sosténgalo
paso tres coloque la otra mano en el
asiento de la Silla o apoyabrazos paso
cuatro mientras soporta su peso en la
silla y las muletas mueva rápidamente su
cuerpo al borde del asiento y empujes
para levantarse sobre su pierna
saludable paso cinco coloque una muleta
debajo de cada brazo para formar un
[Música]
trípode ahora aprenderá Cómo usar las
muletas para subir escaleras con
pasamanos paso uno comience tan cerca de
las escaleras como le sea posible No
importa De qué lado esté el pasamanos ni
cuál sea la pierna
lesionada paso dos mueva la muleta que
está más cerca al pasamanos al brazo
opuesto sostenga ambas muletas con las
agarraderas con esa mano paso tres
agarre el pasamanos con su mano libre
descanse su peso sobre el pasamanos y
las agarraderas de las muletas paso
cuatro levante la pierna sana hacia el
escalón paso cinco empuje las moletas y
usted hacia el siguiente
escalón repita este proceso para cada
paso en los
escalones quizá también necesites subir
escaleras que no tengan
pasamanos paso uno comience tan cerca de
las escaleras como le sea posible
mantenga una muleta bajo cada brazo
ahora recargue su peso sobre las
agarraderas de las
muletas paso dos use su pierna sana para
subir o saltar el siguiente
escalón paso tres empuje las moletas y a
usted hacia el siguiente
escalón repita este proceso para cada
paso en los
[Música]
escalones aquí le mostramos Cómo bajar
escaleras con
pasamanos paso uno tan cerca de las
escaleras como le sea posible No importa
De qué lado esté el pasamanos ni cuál
sea la pierna lesionada paso dos mueva
la muleta que está más cerca al
pasamanos al brazo opuesto sostenga
ambas muletas con las agarraderas con
esa mano paso tres agarre el pasamanos
con el brazo libre paso cuatro coloque
las moletas juntas sobre el siguiente
escalón asegúrese de colocar las moletas
en medio del escalón para poder
balancear su peso
paso cinco mueva lentamente la pierna
lesionada hacia adelante descanse su
peso sobre el pasamanos y las
agarraderas de las muletas paso seis
levante su pierna sana hacia el
siguiente
escalón repita este proceso para cada
paso en los
[Música]
escalones aquí le mostramos Cómo bajar
escaleras sin pasamanos
paso uno comience tan cerca de las
escaleras como le sea posible mantenga
una muleta bajo cada
brazo paso dos apoye hacia adelante y
coloque las muletas en medio del
siguiente escalón ahora recargue su peso
sobre las agarraderas de las muletas
paso tres mueva lentamente la pierna
lesionada hacia adelante paso cuatro
levante su pierna sana hacia el
siguiente
escalón repita este proceso para cada
paso en los
[Música]
escalones ahora Usted ya sabe Cómo
ponerse de pie
sentarse levantarse de una silla caminar
y subir y bajar escaleras con
muletas recuerde hacerlo lentamente al
principio dese tiempo para acostumbrarse
a las
muletas Ponga su peso en las agarraderas
no en las ladillas de las muletas pida
ayuda cuando la
[Música]
necesite